we're out and about in Wharfedale up in
the dales in four I just had lunch go to
wend our way back to the car I'm just in
the queue at Tesco I've just come to get
some last-minute bits and pieces for
either and after see my dad in the Tesco
- hi dad
attack won't see you at home but I can
see you in the desk you
[Music]
we've just had a short but sweet zoom
meeting for our daughter's birthday with
the children and all the grandchildren
and it was lovely but I just seemed to
be having a flat week this week then
that's how it's left me I think I think
um it's really hitting home that it's
going to be a long job before we can do
all the meeting up and hugging and all
the things we used to do I spent about
10 to 15 minutes actually with Camille
but of course our distance in her garden
it's just so natural I don't have to try
and help a child emotionally through
that when a children learning to
interact with people we are open the
game just for takeouts only and social
distancing very slow but it's getting
there it's getting there
Eid Mubarak everyone Eid Mubarak Eid
Mubarak all the lights are up now in my
house this is what I normally do my
three mile jogs Monday to Friday and
today is gonna be quite hard because
it's absolutely jam-packed and there's a
lot of traffic Israel Eid day is nearly
over the children will be even going to
food soon the street is much closer unit
now I feel like a copper set of
neighbors long made
continuum develop